je serai président durant ses jours et
ses semaines autant que je le dois mais
je serai candidat à chaque fois que je
le peux ça y est emmanuel macron est
candidat à sa réélection dix ans avant
lui un autre président se lancer dans la
course un second mandat c'est à nicolas
sarkozy de la base de tout c'est que
depuis 30 ou 40 ans houle a dévalorisé
le travail et tout mon projet c'est de
remettre le travail au centre de tout
[Musique]
le 15 février 2012 nicolas sarkozy se
déclare officiellement candidat à la
présidentielle toute son équipe est
prête et trépigne d'impatience pour
qu'ils descendent dans l'arène le
brouillard de la candidature n'est pas
totalement dissipé mais déjà le qg de
campagne se prépare derrière ces bâches
on s'active pour rafraîchir la peinture
la moquette serait grise à paris au 18
rue de la convention on n'attend plus
qu'une chose l'annnonce de nicolas
sarkozy pour nous pour les militants en
tout cas sur le terrain ils ont vraiment
envie de commencer ils ont vraiment
envie d'y aller ils ont vraiment envie
que l'ensemble de l'ump se met enfin
créer cette cette dynamique il fallait
créer une dynamique car à ce moment là
nicolas sarkozy est distancée dans les
sondages par françois hollande pour se
lancer officiellement dans la bataille
le président choisit le 20 heures de tf1
si j'ai décidé d'être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
c'est parce que j'ai des choses à dire
aux français j'ai des propositions leur
faire
et que les changements que nous avons
engagées dans les cinq années qui
viennent il faut que les français
comprennent que la question essentielle
qui est posée c'est celle que si la
france est forte ils seront protégés et
oui la france forte c'était le slogan de
campagne de nicolas sarkozy en 2012
alors une fois que le président est
officiellement candidat les adversaires
lance la riposte regardez ce que disait
françois hollande le soir même où
nicolas sarkozy s'est déclaré vous
connaissez la nouvelle du jour le
président candidat est désormais
candidat président
j'ai repensé à une phrase que françois
mitterrand avait lui même prononcé il y
a trente ans lorsque le président
sortant valéry giscard d'estaing s'était
lui-même déclaré il avait dit que plutôt
que de présenter sa candidature
il aurait mieux fait de présenter ses
excuses au final après deux mois et demi
de campagne nicolas sarkozy est remonté
peu un peu dans les sondages mais il
s'incline au second tour face à françois
hollande l'ancien président confiera qui
lui a manqué quelques semaines de
campagne supplémentaire pour être réélu
comme quoi attention à ne pas se
déclarer trop tard
[Musique]